Halloween pray bro the one night of the
year we fit in get back
what part and moving the shadows don't
you understand
I've never seen anything like this
before
guys I got a lead on what's going on
since I shudder this one I was building
on has gotta be good
you're a rhinoceros and you're huh I'm a
little piggy
well well
name Casey Jones hey you do guys like a
thing if the purple ooze can turn humans
into animals oh they could turn us
into humans we don't have to be stuck
down here forever if there's a chance
that make us humans for turtles whether
you like it or not gear up guys
Oh
this isn't working we keep family
keep the team unified and you shall
always succeed
let's light them up
Oh
I don't know this is such a good plan no
getting soft on me now yeah
well
got bogeys on the floss okay hit the
button what one there a million buttons
number three number three three
we got company Mikey clear all right
fight nunchucks giganticus
they play
yeah Mikey those things are pretty
awesome huh
pretty awesome
what's happening out there Donny I don't
know it doesn't look good
gear up guys
whoa
my recite bogeys on the bus I think it's
very vital the button what button there
a million buttons
Oh
here we go
what are you superheroes just four
brothers who hate bullies
and love this city 12 well this never
works out well for you
what's your name Casey Joe
one question but you guys like a thing
I'm looking for Aaron Lord we could work
with that
me too is this gonna be good
to bring you back the Mohawk good for
you Oh y'all got jokes huh
why are we going with the Turtles when
something bad happens you want to be
with the Turtles
since I fed her this one I was building
an army it needs to be synthesized which
is where you come
um it was gonna be good
you are right not Souris and your watch
you come up oh I'm a little piggy I like
it me too
we gotta go now we only have a 30-second
window
I don't know if this is such a good plan
listen Matt you free tonight
hey come any kind of fast
nice catch
what is that thing
come on kraang will have ultimate power
is what I was building an army
dude bring you back the Mohawk good for
you Oh y'all got jokes huh
who are these guys
I want to go down swinging these guys
hit harder than anyone you're a guy you
met your match Turtles
no seriously yeah that's my bad I got a
little carried away
no doesn't seem so tough I was expecting
mustache maybe evil goatee or something
good night haver next up big fan big fan
oh my gosh Carmelo Anthony right back at
ya last key to the city oh thank you
yeah I mean they give this things out
hey no - mind if I call you mellow not
at all
listen I'm really glad did you stop me
because guys like you and me were kind
of the same right now we bring a lot of
joy and hope into people's lives we got
that kind of star power and while it's a
gift this Bonnie hey hey no I'd like to
introduce you to my girlfriend
Alessandra girlfriend we just met a week
ago
nice to meet you now we're all over each
other stop it
here we go hang on Mikey come a decaf
ass this is Leonardo
he's our fearless leader let's light him
up
by elves like a cuddly teddy bear if
they cut the teddy bears we're
incredibly violent that's how I roll
that's how you roll Donatello is
technical gene are you doing up there
and I'm Michelangelo I'm a triple threat
brains brawn and a dazzling personality
hey Mikey
guys I got a lead on what's going on
you're a guy
bring back the Mohawk good for you Oh
y'all got jokes huh good I get occasion
when I'm swinging these guys hotter than
anything those things are pretty awesome
huh
we got company
those guys
they're coming back time to take out the
trash
that's how I roll that's how you roll
anything else I can do for you what are
the most important traits for the ninja
speed stealth and precision but
doesn't seem so tough
we wrap that way well coming soon you
live you die you fight as brothers
remember nothing is as strong as family
no chills just a mask see
don't pick out what button there a
million buttons
whoa